the highly-anticipated trailer for
Captain Marvel has arrived let's just
get right into the references and easter
eggs the trailer includes a number of
shoutouts and references to the original
Marvel Comics as it opens we hear 90s
Nick Fury speak and voiceover he says
war is a universal language and refers
to Captain Marvel as a soldier Nick of
course is talking about the kree-skrull
war a significant event in Marvel Comics
lore that was originally written about
in the early 1970s
Captain Marvel herself is biologically
part Cree and a member of that alien
races star force team they're basically
like the Green Lantern's but you know
Marvel and hopefully in a good movie but
you get it space cops the Kree sometimes
also called the rule if you want to get
technical about it are an advanced and
militaristic alien race that becomes
very important as you get into the wider
Marvel cosmology they come from the
planet hala which is located in a real
satellite galaxy near the Milky Way
called the Large Magellanic Cloud we
also get some very quick flashes of Jude
Law's character identified so far as
Walter Lawson but savvy people who are
extremely online have theorized that
he's likely playing the original Captain
Marvel from the comics who was an alien
named Marvel huh let's see what they did
there Marv - Val oh you guys Marvel was
a member of the Kree Imperial militia
who had been sent to observe human
technology on planet earth eventually he
ended up siding with the humans and
became branded a traitor by the Kree oh
and a thing to remember about the kree's
interstellar opponents the scrolls
they are shapeshifters which explains
that shot of Carol punching the old lady
on the train it certainly seems like the
kree-skrull war is coming dangerously
close to Earth in this movie we see an
alien ship arriving just outside Earth's
orbit and then some scrawls in their
natural alien form arriving on a beach
there's also a shot of 90 shield and
what looks like an experiment or even
autopsy being done on a Skrull body all
two eyes Nick Fury holding some kind of
ale
weapon as well and did you see Clark
Gregg as 90s Phil Coulson he's gonna get
a lot more used to aliens in the coming
years there are even more MCU characters
making their glorious return in this
movie at about a minute and a half in we
get Lee pace as our old pal Ronan Djimon
Honsou will also return in this movie as
his guardians of the galaxy character
Korath the pursuer all right let's talk
helmets Carol's classic head wear from
the comics makes two appearances in the
trailer once when she's in space and
once when she's underwater the under the
sea version features not only
crustaceans but the iconic mohawk long
associated with the character captain
Marvel's [ __ ] Punk you guys you don't
even know the trailer gives us a lot of
glimpses of Carol's origin story and how
she got her powers but refuses to give
us any real answers probably because
it's you know the plot the comics also
have a variety of different origins for
Captain Marvel's abilities so we can
only guess as to what specifically is
happening but here's what we can connect
Danvers was originally an Air Force
officer and pilot which explains the
military training we see her undergoing
her flying partner here is Maria Rambo
played in the movie by leshawna Lynch
now in Marvel Comics Maria is the mother
of Monica Rambeau who later becomes part
of the Avengers as the superhero
spectrum at some point during or after
this training Carole probably comes into
contact with some kind of Crete
echnology merging her DNA with that of
the alien species and granting her
powers including superhuman strength and
endurance plus the ability to project
powerful energy beams this is probably
what's going on in that shot where we
see blue flames snaking around her hand
she's absorbing the essence of Creed but
also check out this shot from the very
end of the trailer when Carole seems to
be almost enveloped in a halo of light
this could mean that she's going binary
which in the comic books doubles the
power of her supernatural abilities it's
like she's going super saiyan but she's
already blonde so you just couldn't tell
of course we know it's the 90s when
Carroll crash lands on earth because she
arrives in an active open Blockbuster
video check out the detail on this shot
there's even a little gumball machine in
there remember those
I remember plastic fury already has his
pager which of course he uses in the
final moments on earth to summon Carol
back we saw that in the infinity war
post-credit scene wait what do you mean
you didn't stay after the credits you
still haven't figured that out come on
finally a rare poster Easter egg if you
look in the lower left-hand corner of
the poster just released today you'll
see the back half of a cat in the all
concealing shadow this has got to be
chewy Carroll's faithful companion from
the comics so what's your favorite
moment from the trailer
what 90s reference are you 100%
expecting from this thing how upset will
you be if you don't hear tag-teams won't
there it is at one point
why don't four superheroes have cats let
us know in the comments
you